[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime opera and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime news
cast links are in the description
recommendations go into comments we are
a bit late this week with the news cast
because we had a whole bunch of other
projects other videos that we were
working on we just dropped two new my
hero academia videos and last week we
made a parody of Jake Paul's it's
everyday bro
called its anime bro so if you haven't
checked that out be sure to do that
links in the description now the big
drama of this week is that a few days
ago in one of his daily videos called my
flaws PewDiePie the biggest youtuber of
all time had some not so kind things to
say about anime let's just see exactly
what he said the last one this one is a
tough one I didn't really want to share
this because it's really like personal
but I really like anime and let's get
real here anime is really [ __ ] gay ok
we all know what you all you all know it
anime is the worst thing that has ever
come out of humankind yeah so apparently
PewDiePie wants to go to war with the
anime community he recently said that he
would no longer make any jokes about
Nazis and apparently he assumed that
anime fans are not as extreme well a big
mistake buddy
no actually I'm only kidding if you
watch PewDiePie's videos you know that
he is a huge anime fan and he has been
for a long time at least since like the
early 2000s if not longer and on top of
that PewDiePie is not just like a casual
anime fan either who only watches
mainstream anime some of his favorite
anime and manga include Kaiba Mononoke
and blame also known as Blum and if you
are an anime fan you know that these
titles are not your main stream everyday
titles definitely not outside of Japan
so yeah it's safe to assume that pewds
was only joking here he is obviously a
huge anime nerd and we all know it
however it is also clear that he has
some kind of need to always joke around
about anime and the fact that he watches
anime he has a bit of embarrassment
about it I'm guessing that it's because
he has such a huge audience and he knows
a lot of them don't watch anime and he
thinks it's a nerdy thing to do so he
decides to kind of poke fun at himself
be self-deprecating about his love of
anime but in my own personal opinion and
pewds if you're watching this and I'm
sure you are of course why wouldn't you
be
right right anyways my advice to you
would be to just embrace the fact that
you're a grown man who loves anime I've
done it a long time ago
and I've been happier ever since then
also everybody knows that in 2017 all
the chicks love weaves it's just the
fact it's just a fact by the way just a
quick reminder that on our discord right
now we're organizing a writing contest
and basically what you have to do for
this contest is come up with one or two
pages of a brand new concept for a new
anime so your own idea for an anime
we're gonna take the best ideas and
discuss them live on rant cafe our
podcast that we do here every Thursday
on the channel and yeah there's gonna be
some cool prizes for the winners so if
that's something you're interested in
check out our discord link in the
description in other big news this week
last Friday of course as I'm sure you
know by now the Netflix deathnote
live-action adaptation came out now
there has been a whole lot of discussion
about this movie I don't want to get too
much into it because this Thursday at 5
p.m.
turned Standard Time we're going to be
discussing and ranting about this movie
on rant cafe right here on the channel
live with all of you guys in the chat so
definitely be sure to drop by ran cafe
tomorrow and let me know what you
thought about the movie personally I
thought there was some good stuff and a
lot more bad stuff however I'll save it
for the ran cafe in anime YouTube news
aki dearest recently surpassed the 1
million subscribers milestone which is
just amazing huge congratulations to Aki
as you guys know I've always really
enjoyed her content and she has always
been really supportive of this channel
bad when we were at like 2,000
subscribers
her and Joey actually shouted us out and
invited people to subscribe to us in one
of her videos which meant so much to us
at the time and it still does mean so
much today so yeah again huge congrats
Aki you deserve it and I'm sure you're
just gonna keep growing and growing
faster and faster in the future last
week we learned that two big TV specials
are going to be airing on Japanese
television in October on October 1st a
one piece two-part episode is going to
be airing where Luffy is gonna be
squaring off against Angie and then a
week later on October 8th a dragon ball
super two-part episode special is gonna
be airing we're koku will be facing off
against jiren toy animation released a
quick teaser for the two specials on
YouTube and they seem to be hinting that
that big new Goku transformation new
Super Saiyan form might be appearing in
this special which obviously has a lot
of Dragon Ball super fans going crazy so
I'm looking forward to seeing what is
gonna happen during these specials but
the hype is real by the way for fans of
classic anime and manga the Moroney
Kenshin manga will be coming back on
September 4th and the new anime
adaptation of quino's journey is going
to be airing in October and my favorite
amv of this week is a spongebob anime
opening by Beto Akiva I don't know if
you guys have seen this spongebob anime
opening yet but it is absolutely
hilarious I actually saw it on a
facebook video after a friend of goes
and linked it on our anime upper
Facebook page and I deaf
I recommend watching it it's hilarious
I'm not sure who the original author is
if they have a fate a YouTube page or
not but this MV as well is really funny
definitely worth your time check it out
link in the description and that is it
for this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]